Whether you're discussing what movie to watch...
...or pitching yourself for a promotion,...
...at the end of the day, it's about getting what you want.
Make sure you've done your due diligence,...
...know the facts,...
...and have your evidence boiled down into quick, simple, talking points.
Don't be too eager.
Sit back, get the lay of the land, and let them make the first move.
Know what you're willing to settle for, but don't disclose it.
And be willing to walk away if things go south.
No matter how prepared you are, sometimes you'll be thrown a curveball.
Rethink your strategy and get creative.
There's always a way to bring the conversation back on track.
Finally, a negotiation isn't one meeting, it's a process.
So get in there.